la protesta de los médicos de la ciudad
de Buenos Aires continúa por cuarto día
consecutivo Este martes interrumpieron
más de una docena de puntos vitales para
el tránsito Porteño y se dirigieron
nuevamente hacia el Ministerio de salud
de la ciudad la razón del paro Un
aumento salarial considerable la
situación particular de Argentina
con los conflictos actuales
que haya peor la situación a pesar de
haber pasado un período como la pandemia
donde se supone que éramos esenciales
sentimos más
abandono todavía porque no no Se generó
ningún tipo de esos reconocimientos que
se nos vienen negando de manera
histórica las limitadas condiciones
laborales de los médicos y su poca
remuneración genera que la cantidad de
profesionales disminuya progresivamente
vemos con mucha preocupación el hecho de
que este año muy pocos cupos de
residentes y concurrentes fueron
ocupados históricamente siempre se
llenaban la lista de los hospitales y
Esto va a derivar en que se vayan
formando cada vez menos profesionales de
la salud y obviamente va a repercutir en
una crisis sanitaria a futuro porque
estamos viendo como cada vez menos
compañeros eligen formarse como
especialistas por nuestras condiciones
de trabajo el equipo del jefe de
gobierno Horacio Rodríguez larreta
ofreció 165 mil pesos una cifra por
debajo del monto de la canasta básica y
lejana a los 250 mil pesos que exigen
los manifestantes